the roads and winding lanes are the only
remaining traces of a village now
wiped from the map this is imarat
there were hundreds of homes here just a
few years ago
plus a church a health center schools
all demolished to fuel germany's hunger
for dirty brown
coal all that's left now are memories
i go every day here to the bus
every day to the bus every day from my
house to the bus stop
and now no bus no bus stop
nothing how do you feel sad
it's like mordor here petra grew up here
but there's no trace of her old home
this whole area is due to be engulfed by
a coal mine
owned by rwe the biggest energy company
in germany
the backbone of this nation's industrial
might
imarat was flattened to allow for the
expansion of this
massive open cast coal mine which
supplies a local power station
that is one of the most polluting in the
whole of europe
now the german government has got a plan
to phase out coal but at the same time
this coal mine has got plans to get even
bigger and that would mean the
demolition of more local villages
this is one of them lutzerrad most
residents have sold up and moved
but protesters have come in their place
determined to halt the destruction
and some of them living in trees as they
plan how to stop the looming demolition
we are rich in germany we have
a high income high living standards and
we need to
start making changes here because we can
for other protesters there is
inspiration from a german hero
beethoven
in another of the area's condemned
villages a farm has been turned into an
impromptu
concert venue stage to throw a spotlight
on the plight of this region
hear the names of villagers that have
either gone or which are set to be
bulldozed
the man organizing this concert is
norbert he's lived on the farm for his
entire life
and the specter of the mine expansion
now haunts him
when you hear these excavators running
and you see the light from the mine very
very
bright light and no one is here
then it's very it puts a lot of pressure
on you
and there is something discordant here
germany has pledged to phase out coal by
2038
and yet here is europe's richest country
pummeling communities
in pursuit of lignite the most polluting
form of coal
so why do it rwe told us that abandoning
coal power
has to happen gradually and insist the
destruction
can't be stopped lignite mining means
advancing through the landscape
and you can't just kind of leave out one
space and switch
to another one you would have to open a
new mine
and that's that would not be feasible
and it's got something to do with the
law and this coal exit law
says that guards viola mine
is necessary for the security of supply
in germany beyond 2030
back at the concert a storm breaks out a
deluge
drenches the farm but the musicians play
on
around here resilience is a very
precious virtue
adam parsons sky news western german